Speaker 1: So as we get into the spring and
eventually the summer, we're going to be
talking more and more about 2022 primary races
and midterm races and just races in general. As
many of you know, there's an interesting Senate
race happening in Ohio. This is the race in which
J.D. Vance, who is the author of the book
Hillbilly Elegy, which really wasn't a bad book,
but he's gone completely off the rails. J.D.
Vance is a candidate. Trump is Josh Mandel
is a candidate. And at a recent debate within
this race, a physical fight almost broke out,
which included you guys. I'm sure anybody who's
been to a bar. Knows these situations where to
I mean, it's it's two men I've never seen women
do this at a bar. They start doing the thing
where they puff up. It's almost like a peacock
or, you know, certain animals that kind of like
there's some frogs that like blow up their chest
and certain birds. I don't know if tit mice do it
or what kind of birds they kind of just start
puffing themselves up and start almost chest
bumping. And it's kind of like a battle to see who
will back down first. That which normally is that
happening at bars took place at the Republican
primary debate. It's really, really wacky. The
Times of Israel reporting near fight at Ohio
Republican Senate debate between candidates Josh
Mandel and Mike Gibbons after Mandel repeatedly
interrupts him, Gibbons accuses the former soldier
of not knowing how investments work, which
was a that was a fair criticism, leading
the latter to stand up and accost his rival. And
we have video of this if you're only listening.
You'll have to imagine what it's like, although
we'll have the clip up on our Instagram and on our
tick tock. These are the frontrunners, guys, and
we'll look at polling in a moment, but this is how
cartoonish and childish and pathetic
some of these races are. Check this out.
Speaker 2: No, you don't. I do. You've never
looked better in your work, Sasquatch person. I
ran for me. I had to work to rescue. People don't
know squat. So you don't know squat. Two tours in
Iraq. Don't tell me I been work off and
back on like, am I ever going to sit down?
Unidentified: Never switch.
Squared away, or do you want to
watch what happened last, you watch that?
Speaker 1: Yeah, you watch what happens. So
threats being issued now, I don't know. You know,
you guys will have to tell me who comes off as the
alpha male in that situation. It's it's it's
genuinely hard for me to tell. And meanwhile,
J.D. Vance, who did not participate
in that but is part of this race,
sat to the side thinking, Obviously, this really
benefits me, although he's not polling that well.
These are the frontrunners in the Ohio Republican
Senate primary. We have the polling here.
The latest here is these are average
average average. Gibbons is polling twenty.
Mendell is at eighteen point seven, so that's
basically a tie. It's almost within the margin
of error. J.D. Vance is down at 11 percent
and two other candidate, Timken and Dolan,
are almost where J.D. Vance is. Patel with
a point and a half. So that's an interesting
race. And what's fascinating about it
is the least delusional people. Um,
well, I can't even say that the most obviously
delusional people are some of the ones doing the
best. Mendell is an absolute lunatic. I mean, just
a complete and total lunatic. And if you actually
go and look at his political record, you see that
this is just a massive, massive pro-Trump guy.
And he has backed the election fraud claims of
Trump. He says that the 2020 election was stolen.
He says if he wins, he will carry forward
Trump's agenda. Now what's funny about that is
it's not clear Trump really had an agenda other
than just self-aggrandizement and, you know,
putting himself in positions of power. He said the
Trump impeachment was a sham. He will fight for
the America first agenda. He says we will soon
see the evidence coming out of the widespread
voter fraud. I mean, that's like that's verbatim
what Trump says, and he's tied for first place,
essentially tied for first place with
Gibbons. So it's a very difficult primary
to kind of make heads or tails out of because
so many wacky people in there and they don't
seem to be hurt by saying and doing crazy
things, we'll see if the polling in any way
is impacted. If anybody is going to benefit from
that confrontation. You would think it would be
J.D. Vance, although there might be Republican
voters who like that and you say, No, I liked
Gibbons before, and I liked that Gibbons didn't
back down or I liked Mandel before, and I liked
that Mandel didn't back down, and they both puffed
up their chests. At this point, I don't pretend to
know what Republican voters are going to like,
but we'll soon see it reflected in the polling